ma anche solo capello in l'occhio al
numero 20 oggi ho deciso di dare una
rassettata alla casa che fa un po schifo
sto soltanto qualsiasi cosa
quindi nel frattempo per coprire questo
vuoto stanzetta nel secondo acqua nel
frattempo per coprire questo modo volevo
mettere delle clip del vita buttate di
ieri che non ho montato alla fine che
però mi fa molto ridere e quindi vi
faccio vedere oggi
adesso mentre io faccio la mary poppins
di turno rumori io ho paura
diciamo una roba che è stata creata per
gli anziani ed estate dice come questa
roba questa segrete per gli anziani per
massaggiarsi la prima richiesta che ne
preso esatto dallo scorso le mie amiche
mi hanno regalato questo bracciale a
formati fortieri troppo anti estetico
non è a furgoni forchetta è però detta
questo mese a metterla ho capito ma
quando avanti piccola
magari è così vedi che hai fatto
ieri ho fatto questa stories questo
numero delle palle alle elettriche ha
mai fatto è stata quella di due anni fa
quando mi hanno regalato una borsa con
le sembianze di un topo
il verdetto con un cinturino nero di
pelle finita
che bravo molto bravo complimenti per
ora sei il mio regalo di preferito è
bellissimo gol
mara che bello fluente tutto ventura
vestivano appostano e avessi ma guarda
la cura nel ricreare è bellissimo che è
stato il regalo più brutto come ricevuto
è stata una cassa se quel giocattolo per
bambini che tu metti non c'è mckee soldi
fece già una cassa perché perché avevo
iniziato l'università facevo economia
una cassa la cassa del supermercato
io non so non capivo che infatti avesse
avuto questa ragazza con le casse dei
bambini e obeso una cassa inizialmente
una cassa che sfumava all'apparenza
sembrerebbe un bellissimo regalo da
regalare ad un'amica messo curamente
lunga il gruppo le persone normali ci
piace la disney eccetera eccetera
peccato che la mia amica è ammalata
vedendo questa foto vede solo dei pianti
ciao v allora mia zia è la solita fare
regali a natale allora come ogni anno mi
regala un abbonamento che io odio
abbastanza a vedere dei balletti
classici ti odio la danza classica
quindi è perfetto ed è da sei anni che
non avevano
in secondo luogo due anni fa mi ha
regalato questo bellissimo fazzoletto ed
il world ricamato bianco e giallo con
scritto il mio nome
lo scorso natale un'amica di mia madre
mi ha regalato una cosa molto molto
brutta
cerchi brillantinati ma questa non è la
cosa peggiore
la marca della collana era non so se si
può dire che comunque a nick rosa
grandiosa a nino saggi inediti la
felicità di una futura mamma anni rosa
che dire io direi che siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video
ma prima di lasciarci credo sia giusto
forse sì ricordare e vedere quella che è
stata la clip che più di ogni altra cosa
ha conquistato il cuore di milioni di
italiani e stavo per perdere un polmone
che dire guardiamola è un sex toy con me
il fatto che un avvitatore che proprio
insuperabile cioè io non lo so un
oggetto così bello da tutti i punti di
vista non ho mai visto ho finito di dare
una rassettata alla cucina
bentornati ragazze in questo blog mas
che è sempre più simile a una puntata di
vita buttava in realtà perché sto
sprecando la mia vita pressa cose
inutili tipo fissare il monitor del mio
computer per ore guardando video
ultimamente a sta cosa che mi sto
guardando ad esso ha una tizia e un
altro tizio che fanno ballando con le
stelle junior a in america e la mia
giornata va così bene benissimo
in tutto questo sto anche cercando tipo
di organizzare il natale che quest'anno
vorremmo cucinare noi ragazzi per gli
adulti che stanno un pochino incasinati
poverini con varie cose di famiglia che
non vi sto a raccontare
non sono interessanti non voglio
rattristare nessuno credente cucinerò a
natale
che bello questa giornata la sto
passando a mangiare questo per farvi
capire runcini teneri marinati con
frutti di bosco
la salvezza di questa giornata posso
dirvelo enrico si è preso cioccolato e
napoli mentre invece che ha portato
naturalmente mary a me hanno lasciato
cioccolato e menta che per me l'arte
rete il male ma dai vediamolo camera vi
fregate quadri con cui tutto questo ho
letto un messaggio o sotto al vita
buttata di ieri che mi ha molto colpito
per quanto in realtà molto giusto
scusatemi se il cioccolato di un ragazzo
che mi aspetta diceva la seguente cosa
voglio leggerlo ok viene buttata con un
con matteo allora scrive andrea
probabilmente mi beccherò insulti altro
non volevo dire che questi video sono
partiti bene divertenti e tutto mentre
da qualche video ormai non ci si
concentra il meno più su cosa dice la
gente ma sul come lo dice non riesco più
ad a divertirmi a vedere ogni volta voi
che prendete ovviamente senza cattiveria
essere chiaro per il culo tutte ste
persone che si prestano al gioco il
praticamente nemmeno ascoltate per
quello che dicono la mia opinione
personale no non voglio insinuare altro
di cui non vorrei che non ce l'ho
scritto sopra
e questo momento ma subito fatto
rispondere a questo ragazzo e lo sto
dicendo perché ci tengo particolarmente
a non sembrare henan per rive le persone
allora gli ho detto 0 insulti anche
perché di base se una persona chi fa una
critica così costruttivo non vedo perché
debba beccarsi insulti da parte di
qualcuno e anzi sarebbe vergognoso che
qualcuno ma persona così gentile dovesse
portare un insulto o cattivo anzi grazie
per la dritta per caso estremamente
costruttiva volevo dire questo
sicuramente sbaglio perché io in buona
fede
penso sempre quando ricevo un messaggio
di scherzare con un amico e io spesso ai
nemici
esco fuori contesto incomincio capito
quando mi raccontano aneddoti
ha scherzato a scherzarci attorno a
farli il verso e da una cosa che mi
viene istintivo specialmente poi se ho
alcune persone vicino a me che mi stiano
questa cosa mi rendo conto glielo ha
detto pure a lui che sicuramente chi ti
manda un video non è un tuo amico e che
quindi forse bisogna avere meno
confidenza
detto ciò volevo proprio prendermi
questo momento per ringraziarvi per
quando mi postate delle critiche
costruttive come come questa perché io
ne prendo in considerazione me ne metto
in tasca e sono cose alle quali
normalmente faccio attenzione
praticamente ne leggo i commenti per
dirlo e li prende considerazione niente
mi dispiace magari per dei ragazzi che
hanno mandato dei video o degli audio e
hanno pensato che ci fossero mancanza di
rispetto a con non è quello e magari c'è
una eccessiva confidenza in quel caso me
la riprendo giuro anzi a voi vi darò del
lei la prossima volta
e questa è una battuta lo giuro ragazzi
sono da tipo un'ora su questo divano e
nel testo di alzarmi per colpa sua
perché quando un cane sta così come puoi
dirgli vattene creativa oddio se come sa
cosa potremmo fare una sfida io e te di
disegno con enrico pure tu visto farafra
frog nel suo canale si facciamo questa
sfida che ho visto è una ragazza
bravissima dei disegni bellissimo lo sa
disegnare e pazzesco l'ala stiamo per
fare
disegniamo dei pokémon sono solo dalla
loro descrizione
interessa il tuo adesso giochi come
allora ho rubato mio fratello enrico ai
due minuti per fare un pokémon che ti
descriverò che uscirà qui da da questo
generatore random di pokemon che vuol
dire generatore random praticamente poi
c'è questa applicazione tu metti
generare e ti compare un pokémon e tu lo
devi di scrivere velocemente all'altra
persona ruvesi sentimenti proprio non si
sono resistenti
nel video di franco che si scopre tipo
che c'è stato 600 800 non lo so quanto i
suoi andiamo a siamo pronti vediamo cosa
ci sei
disegna un coniglio le orecchie sono
fatte tipo tipo klonoa è un po più unite
più unite un buon orecchio più magro un
po più corpo più piccolo mai troppo
tardi per dimagrire
[Risate]
poi basta e finito questo è un po questo
è un po un coniglio che generiamo lo
comunque carino allora devi fare un
semicerchio sopra tipo una cupola ok a
questo punto vicino al becco dobbiamo
fare un occhio che è un ovale in piedi
quasi un uovo con il luccichio
nell'occhio petilli un'ala di lato una
letta che un tondino tipo alla fine due
pennine che escono piccoline 3 piume
sotto al collo senza staccare mai la
penna e dall'altro lato era e richiude
il collo a questo punto gli fai un corpo
sotto che chiude tutto quanto vale e
delle gambette da pennuto attiva ma che
più mi sono lui flatting ma scusa m
totalmente di mi.fi poi un uccello
[Risate]
allora generiamo ok disegnami una
scimmia
no aspetta è un sorriso uno smile no no
no no ventana ricky finire prima
la faccia un po più male male male
sembra tutto sembra piuttosto cose ok
fatto sto mostro disegno la scimmia
pranzo disegnando ecco cosa devo fare
tommy delle dritte non mi lasciare solo
[Musica]
io sono stato abbandonato nella scimmia
[Risate]
segui le indicazioni ma perché non mi ha
detto fai un ovale fai delle travature
hai fatto di corsa è fatto di così
niente ei pon lui è fra queste
comincia a fare una linea ondulata sotto
la bondola ondula sotto avanti con la
così tanto durata ok continua permetto
somma delle narici aspirarla sì proprio
due tratti ninì fermo bravissimo
duramente in 21 in su due denti uno su
perfetto tutti attaccati perfetto come
doveva essere una cresta una cresta
adesso che sono da triangoli pali stia
fermo sotto gli facciamo una bella pappa
gorgona una mappa corcione gratis
mamma mia fagli ora il corpo di denver è
un pellicano vairano il bravissimo penso
contenuti l'effetto pacman chiudili la
testa chiudere la testa la sa aperta
ok per me gabibbo manuela ma poi nord
era fate capire l'abbondanza del sotto
vedove nidi e poi un coccodrillo è
invece l'ho fatta fa lui ha fatto fa
maurizio costanzo ok una tigre dai denti
a sciabola fi senza i baffi è un felino
non è un ippopotamo
mia mamma da un anno e coda non c'è ma
non era facilissimo ebraico fateci
sapere che ha vinto ho vinto io
unanimi di iscrizioni sono state milioni
come dire i ragazzi fatemi sapere che ha
detto è che dire noi ci vediamo domani
con un altro blog mas sempre alle 14
nella puntata di domani è
particolarmente materialmente speciale
quindi non perdete bravo ciao ciao ciao
ragazzi